i suppose for me my biggest problem that  i'm physically aware of is my intake of  coca-cola love the brand but obviously  it doesn't love me  i'm taking part in this program simply  that i need to make a bit of a life  change  time has come where i need to actually  seek some advice and move forward in a  more positive way to hopefully lose some  weight what are you making kayla  whipped cream  you got a predilection to develop type 2  diabetes the reason is there's a  darkening of the  axilla which is armpit it's called  there's a condition called acanthosis  nigricans that means darkening of the  skin that tells me there's a problem  with insulin resistance and there's a  chance of you developing type 2 diabetes